In the 1950s U.S. forces were stretched dangerously
thin.
U.S. President Dwight D Eisenhower stated
of this, “My feeling…remains, that it
would be impossible for the United States
to maintain the military commitments which
it now sustains around the world (without
turning into a garrison state) did we not
possess atomic weapons and the will to use
them when necessary.”
No surprise from this that, unsatisfied with
the portability of their shiny new M65 nuclear
cannons, which required a couple of very large
trucks to transport, and further unsatisfied
that firing it off in many tactical situations
would be a bit like killing a mosquito with
a hand grenade, in the late 1950s the U.S.
military brass for once were thinking smaller.
What they really wanted was a simple weapon
that could launch a miniature nuclear warhead,
could be carted around by a few soldiers,
and be fired relatively quickly and reliably.
This would allow a handful of soldiers to
successful combat far superior forces on the
other side, even at relatively close range,
which none of the other nuclear weapons of
the age could safely do- Enter the Davy Crockett.
Rumor has it the name was chosen in homage
to the famed American politician owing to
the legend that he once grinned a bear to
death, with the idea referencing the association
between Russia, and the Soviet Union in general,
with bears.
Whether that’s actually the reasoning behind
the name or not, the first prototype of the
Davy Crockett was completed in November of
1958 and ultimately deployed about two and
a half years later in May of 1961.
Featuring a variant of the W54 warhead contained
in an M388 round, the projectile was fired
from an M-28 or M-29 smooth bore recoilless
gun.
This was capable of launching the 10 or 20
ton yield nuke as far as about 1.25 miles
for the M28 or 2.5 miles for the M29.
As for portability, the Davy Crockett could
be either deployed and fired from the back
of a jeep for maximum mobility, or even broken
down into its components, with the pieces
of the weapon carried by five soldiers on
foot.
The general procedure for firing the 76 pound
nuclear round was quite simple.
First a spotting round would be shot from
an attached gun to ensure the weapon was aimed
reasonably well.
After this, in order to get the nuke to end
up more or less where the spotting round did,
the angle of the gun would have to be adjusted.
To do this, a small book with pre-calculated
tables was carried giving adjustment figures
for said angle.
However, it turns out test firings with non-live
nukes showed again and again that the Davey
Crockett was an obscenely inaccurate weapon,
possibly both because of the angle adjustment
and that the weapon itself was smooth bore.
Of course, the fact that the Davey Crockett
was shooting a nuclear warhead helped make
this inaccuracy issue not as much of a problem
as would be the case with other similar weapons.
Once the target was mildly locked on, the
propellant charge would be inserted into the
muzzle with a metal piston placed in after
as a sort of cap.
This was followed by the M388 round itself
containing the W54 warhead.
As the M388 was far too big to fit inside
the bore, instead a rod would be attached
to the back, with the nuke sitting at the
front.
As for how the warhead would know when to
detonate, there was a timer dial that would
be set based on estimated distance to the
target, using figures given in the aforementioned
book containing a spreadsheet of tables.
However, contrary to what is often stated,
the timer was not actually the thing that
triggered detonation.
Rather, it simply armed the bomb once the
time ran out.
The actual trigger for detonation was a simple
radar device in the back of the M388 that
would detect how far above the ground the
nuke was.
There was also a high and low switch that
could slightly adjust height of detonation
based on the radar reading.
As you might have gleaned from all this, also
contrary to what is often stated, this switch
did not control the yield of the bomb, just
what height it would detonate above the ground,
roughly 20-40 feet AGL, depending on setting.
It should also be noted that, unlike many
other nuclear weapons, this was an otherwise
dumb nuke.
Once the timer was set and it was fired, it
would either go off or prove itself to be
a dud.
There was no aborting detonation after launch.
If all that is involved in firing the Davey
Crockett sounds like it might take a long
time, it turns out not at all given the destructive
power of this weapon.
One former Davey Crockett section soldier,
Thomas Hermann, notes that they were actually
trained and well capable of firing a nuke
every two and a half minutes!
So just how deadly could this weapon be?
While extremely low-powered as nukes go, the
weapon nonetheless produced a blast in the
ballpark of as large as the highest yield
non-nuclear explosive devices of the era.
But unlike many of these, it was relatively
small and portable.
More important than that was its potential
for extended damage long after the initial
blast.
This was particularly useful when fired around
critical routes that enemy soldiers would
have to traverse.
Not only would the initial blast do significant
damage to any soldiers and enemy vehicles
around at the time, but the radioactive fallout,
which would almost certainly be fatal to anyone
within about a quarter of a mile of the initial
blast when it went off, would remain long
after, making a given route, such as a mountain
pass, impassable for several days after if
one was interested in not dying of radiation
poisoning.
Naturally, the Soviets could defend against
this simply by equipping each of their soldiers
with lead-lined refrigerators, but for whatever
reason they never seemed to have chosen to
go this route.
On the other end of things, neither did the
Americans.
This was despite the fact that the Davey Crockett
was also not terribly safe for those firing
it.
While 1.25-2.5 miles away is plenty of range
to keep the soldiers who pulled the trigger
safe from being harmed by the blast itself,
in real world scenarios the enemy being fired
upon could be closer and some of your own
troops might also be even closer still.
Critical to all of this was also wind direction.
With no wind, the radiation kill zone in the
immediately aftermath of the blast was approximately
1,500 feet, but wind could easily blow dangerous
radioactive particles towards one’s own
troops.
As such, crew were instructed to, if possible,
only fire the gun when suitable cover behind
a hill or the like was available to help reduce
radiation exposure.
That said, presumably to try to get the soldiers
operating the weapon to be slightly less hesitant
about firing it, the instruction manual notes
that the leader of the troop should instill
a great sense of urgency in the soldiers operating
the Davy Crockett and to remember that, to
quote, “The search for nuclear targets is
constant and vigorous!”
On top of that, the manual states that if
the nuke failed to detonate for some reason,
the soldiers should wait a half hour and then
go and recover the supposed to be armed and
ready to detonate at the whim of a radar trigger
nuke…
Needless to say, while the Davy Crockett was
deployed everywhere from West Germany to South
Korea, with well over 2,000 of the M388 rounds
made and 100 of the guns deployed, it was
never actually used in battle.
That said, the Army did do one test fire of
the Davy Crockett with a live M388 round.
This occurred during Operation Sunbeam in
a test code named “Little Feller I”, which
took place on July 17, 1962.
The nuke flew approximately 1.7 miles and
detonated successfully about 30 feet above
the ground, with an estimated yield of 18
tons from the blast.
Interestingly enough, this was the last time
the United States would detonate a nuke in
the air close to the ground thanks to the
1963 Treaty Banning Nuclear Weapon Tests in
the Atmosphere, in Outer Space and Under Water.
(And, yes, that is the real name of the treaty).
In the end, as cool as having a portable nuclear
gun is and all, within only a few years the
weapon would become antiquated, and by 1967
the Army was already beginning to phase it
out, with it going the way of the Dodo completely
by 1971.
No doubt to the eternal relief of the soldiers
tasked with firing the things should
the need arise.